it is time for drink news your
bottomless basket of good news french
fries
and with me at the desk is the finest
co-pilot there is it's rossi ross
matthews give me one of those fries hi
everybody hi
and today we have got an epic desk guest
i am so excited for this person to come
out she is just a force
and her live show will really actually
change your life and now she stars in
this very
very uh anticipated highly talked about
exciting
new show on hbo called somebody
somewhere take a look
i like to sit down and write out a list
of goals for the week and
then of course i write down a list of
accomplishments for the previous week
and
oh my god that's so amazing
i don't do any of that
i like to lay around drinking wine in my
underwear
very favorite women comedians again you
are everything bridgette everett
[Applause]
yeah oh my god i know you're right it
does have a little
little something a little giddy up in
here yeah i'm so excited to be here oh
my god
we're so honored that you would grace
our show with your presence i am not
kidding 100
i am i met bridget in the hallway
about five minutes ago and i literally
screamed i love you so much
i love you and your show
is so unbelievably phenomenal and
heartfelt and real and i laughed and i
cried watching it it was all the feels
so thank you for making your new show
thank you so great thank you so much
you're so welcome i i'm a crier i'm very
vulnerable rudy's my favorite movie you
know like
you know just like those kind of movies
where the dreamers finally like
like he does not give up on himself yeah
and i did for many years i just was
waiting tables which is nothing wrong
with that but
that's kind of all i felt like i was
capable of but i still kind of kept
going for
because there was still something inside
of me but when i got to my 40s i was
like you need to start listening to the
thing that's inside of you oh god yes i
think so many people can relate to that
right well you just aren't where you
want to be yeah and look at you now look
at you now it's amazing what you've done
thank you thank you speak for that
i love you
a little bit of everything well
bridgette we do love to hit the
headlines around here and i was
wondering if you'll hit some with us
yeah you're ready let's do it i want to
hit them real hard
okay um well first we all need those
friends who will shoot it to us straight
even when it hurts because that's
exactly when we need to hear it so it's
no surprise that elton john is just that
kind of friend
insider report singer charlie puth
revealed his pal elton told him quote
those songs he put out in 2019 were no
good and he said that elton had it right
he was working with too many
collaborators and he kind of lost
himself with everybody else and he just
needed a little reset um bridget do you
have the hard-hitting friends and do you
like that oh yeah you know um a lot of
people know i'm good friends with amy
schumer and she's very direct she gets
to the point and i appreciate that you
know a lot of times but sometimes i also
just want to be you know wrapped up in a
drew raw sandwich
oh no i think it's important some of the
most crucial points in my life is when
someone who loved me told me i was doing
it wrong or doing something wrong or not
being the best version of myself and it
was tough man it's a gut punch when you
hear that but when you look back if you
listen to those people that love you
it'll change your life right well just
like in movie uh in the movie rudy
they help move you down the field by
giving you the ball you know you got to
take the ball rash you really got to run
with this you know so
it's really about reach
can you know everything everything could
go back to rudy it's a perfect movie i
would like to challenge you every news
story if you could bring it back to rudy
somehow today
that's not a challenge that's a that's
an invitation all right well let's
try it
[Music]